[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview sur
rtl france nous sommes avec l'économiste
bissao guinéen carlos lopez ancien
secrétaire exécutif de la commission
économique pour l'afrique des nations
unies professeur à l'université du cap
et aussi à sciences po paris bonjour un
carlos lopez bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors vous êtes
au cap
d'abord cette question comment les
autorités sud-africaines gère justement
cette crise sanitaire plutôt bien pour
la surprise de beaucoup de monde parce
que normalement avant la crise il y
avait des dissensions au sein du
gouvernement sur un certain nombre des
mesures de tout ordre notamment de
chapitre économique et tout d'un coup il
ya un consensus national autour de la
réponse aux qu'ovide mais aussi des
mesures assez courageuse et très bien
géré jusqu'à ce moment et aussi les
sauces et en ce qui concerne le
confinement on a pu observer des scènes
parfois un petit peu violente
vous savez il ya une tradition de
certaines violences la part de la police
et des certains groupes qui se
confrontent chaque fois qu'ils ont
l'opportunité c'est une est un héritage
de l'apartheid et de des niveaux
d'inégalités assez exacerbant dans ce
pays mais je pense que il faut vraiment
voir le contexte il est isolé un peu
sicav donc dans la majorité
les sud africains suivent les règles de
confinement avec beaucoup de peine pour
ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens mais avec
un cd discipline alors on va parler
évidemment de l'impact économique de
cette pandémie en afrique
s'agissant de l'afrique du sud qui est
la première économie du continent
africain
est-ce qu'elle ait des choses de
conserver ce seront je pense que l'euro
peut-être parce que notamment à ce qui
concerne les deux compétiteurs les plus
importants l'egypte et le nigeria les
dégâts seront aussi considérable que
ceux de l'afrique du sud
mais à mon avis vraiment l'afrique du
sud va souffrir énormément de points de
vue économique
parce qu'elles avaient déjà tous les
éléments de crise avoir co vide
notamment les agences de rating l'ont
déclassé au niveau vraiment des
sous-investissements et je pense que
c'était juste une conséquence d'un
certain nombre des problèmes
macroéconomiques mais aussi de manque de
croissance qui s'éternise depuis presque
une décennie donc l'afrique du sud n'a
pas réussi vraiment répondre aux besoins
de création d'emplois et tout ça va
vraiment remonté en termes de proportion
en ce qui concerne les conséquences du
coup vite et je pense qu'on peut
attendre à une décroissance de
l'économie de l'ordre de 6% alors autres
prévisions au niveau continental ont
fait que les prévisions de l'om est-ce
de l'onu elles sont plutôt alarmistes
vous étiez vous en poste à l'onu à
l'époque justement d'ebola au plus fort
de l'épidémie d'ebola l'afrique a eu
donc à gérer de nombreuses crises
sanitaires elle a prouvé aussi ses
capacités de résilience est ce que ces
institutions que j'ai cités ont raison
d'être aussi alarmiste selon vous je
pense qu'il ya un peu trop d'exagération
et je le prendrai toute franchise
pendant la période de l'ebola gdi de
même je me rappelle qu'il y avait une
prévision de la banque mondiale et du
fmi à l'époque d'une dans l'appart
économique de 3 33 milliards de dollars
dans l'ensemble du continent
et à mon avis c'était une grande
exagération parce que les trois pays
concernés le plus sierra leone la guinée
et le liberia est fait représenter à peu
près 6 milliards de dollars d'économies
et donc ça me paraissait vraiment
complètement hors proportion est
finalement à la france et seulement 3
milliards de dollars d'impact qu'on a vu
donc il y avait une exagération de 30
milliards je pense que dans ce cas de
figure que tel que les jarrets
l'exagération ne vient pas à dix points
de vue économique là je pense que les
gens ont raison vraiment de prévoir une
situation assez pessimiste mais plutôt
l'exagération via des impacts sanitaires
je pense que l'afrique va souffrir
beaucoup plus économiquement que du
point de vue sanitaire
pour des raisons qui sont maintenant de
plus en plus analysé mais pas encore
complètement clair le fait que nous
avons une pyramide d'âge qui est assez
jeune
le fait que nous avons cette résilience
que vous avez mentionné l'utilisation de
la chloroquine et des antirétroviraux
qui donne à la population africaine des
caractéristiques différentes par rapport
à la virologie qui est aussi le fait que
nous avons une certaine connaissance des
épidémies et donc les gens à qui
certains comportements qui est assez
résilient des points de vue mais des
limites des militaires est ce qu'il faut
craindre aussi une crise alimentaire une
famine on a vu des scènes de panique
dans certains pays africains avec 73
millions de personnes touchées quand
même par une crise alimentaire
ce sont les dernières estimations dans
quelle mesure cette pandémie du colis de
19 risque d'aggraver les choses
voilà ça c'est la troisième crise parce
que à part la sanitaire qui est hélas il
la crise économique nous allons avoir
une crise de sécurité alimentaire qui
est en grand partie proposée par des
phénomènes qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les covit nous avons dans la région
d'afrique australe une sécheresse qui
s'étend depuis quatre ans et qui affecte
particulièrement certain nombre de pays
notamment la namibie le botswana
l'angola la zambie partie de l'afrique
du sud nous avons les criquets qui
envoyait la corne de l'afrique qui ont
vraiment détruit une bonne partie de
culture et nous avons disons la crise
qui se pérennise au sahel notamment
sécuritaires qui empêche que
l'agriculture puisse contribuer
complètement la sécurité alimentaire de
la zone
donc nous avons ce phénomène qui n'ont
rien à voir avec nico vide mais bien sûr
ajouter aux convives créer une situation
de pénurie parce que d'une part il ya
une logistique beaucoup plus compliqué
donc les coûts de transport ont augmenté
mais surtout la la capacité d'accès à
des marchands d apporter est devenue
telle que nous avons vraiment une crise
de stockage et bien sûr nous avons aussi
toute la l'arrêt des activités
économiques qui empêche la distribution
de ce qui existe déjà et qui fait
vraiment détruire une bonne partie de la
production par manque justement
d'activité donc nous avons vraiment une
crise devant nous qui est assez sévère
est ce que tous les pays africains vont
être impactés on parlait tout à l'heure
l'afrique du fus pour le plan économique
je pense que tous seront impactés mais
pour des raisons différentes
nous avons un certain nombre de pays
enclavé qui ont des difficultés de
logistique de notre grandeur pas
habituel et qui vont payer des prix
vraiment très ample actionner pour tout
transport nous avons une crise de ceux
qui dépendent beaucoup du tourisme
non seulement parce qu'il n'y aura pas
touristes mais on a aussi beaucoup de
difficultés avec les transports aériens
nous avons d'autres qui auront subi des
conséquences des réductions dramatiques
du prix des matières premières nous
avons 35 pays africains qui sont dans la
catégorie des plus dépendants des points
de vue et mondial des matières premières
parce qu'ils ont plus de 80% de leurs
exportations qui dépendent des matières
premières elles sont toutes en descente
libres et nous avons un certain nombre
de pays avec des économies modernes très
sophistiqué corne de l'afrique du sud
qui vont beaucoup subir des problèmes de
taux de change parce que leurs monnaies
vont être fortement dépréciés et aussi
des problèmes de fuites de capitaux
comme c'est le cas déjà l'afrique du sud
presse pour 4% de leur pib et donc je
pense que l'ensemble de ces
caractéristiques selon de nature à
montrer que le continent va voir
vraiment une de ses pires années de ses
tantes dernière même si les conséquences
sont différentes selon les pays
alors les solutions on sait que emmanuel
macron le président français a prôné une
annulation de la dette des pays
africains mais au final on a abouti à un
moratoire décidé par le g20
est-ce que c'est impossible
véritablement d'annuler la dette des
pays africains les pays riches n'ont pas
les moyens
moi je pense que ce qui a décidé le g20
c'est vraiment une goutte d'eau
ça ça ne porte pas vraiment un bénéfice
au pays offrant ce qu'ils ont décidé
c'est que pour les pays les plus
fragiles les plus pauvres ce qui ne
représente pas grand chose du point de
vue des valeurs absolues
on va pousser leur paiement des intérêts
de cette année d'éventuellement de
l'année prochaine une partie de cette
décision c'est un appel donc ce n'est
même pas quelque chose qui est encore
confirmer parce que une partie des
acteurs peuvent encore penser autrement
et disons-le introduit entre guillemets
une conditionnalité qui fait planer la
possibilité de l'austérité puisque on
dit qu'il faut avoir un cadre
macroéconomique parfait ce qu'on ne
demande pas aux pays riches 1 parce que
justement on dit qu'il faut oublier un
peu les déficits fiscaux et tout le
reste pour eux donc au fond c'est ce
pardon il donne un tout petit peu
d'oxygène à certains pays pas beaucoup
et ça ne touche pas la majorité des pays
africains et donc je pense que ça ne
servira pas très loin dans la poêle à à
la proposition du président macro je
suis beaucoup plus excité avec la partie
dans laquelle il prône disons que qu'on
pardonne complètement la dette d'une
bonne partie des pays il parle de
massivement et je pense qu'il a raison
parce qu'en valeur absolue la dette
africaine c'est un peu pressé 100
milliards de dollars
donc ça ne fait pas grand chose même si
on l'a réglé shon et si on si on fait la
restructuration de cette dette
on en est la clé loi et c'est beaucoup
plus important que de pousser tout
simplement les intérêts qui seront
payées cette année des quelques mois ou
quelques années
pourquoi emmanuel macron il n'est pas
suivi finalement est-ce qu'à une forme
d'hypocrisie ville
du continent africain je pense que c'est
assez tabou de pardonner des dettes
surtout parce qu'on a pardonné la dette
africaine récemment donc dans l'année
2000 enfin la fin des années 90 dans
l'allée de me donne à coup on a démarré
avec dix ont une dette qui était assez
faible et les gens regardent ça et
compare avec la situation actuelle où
nous avons un ratio de dette par rapport
à notre richesse nationale 2 entre 50 et
60% et ses dix bons commencé à remonter
si vite donc c'est une espèce de
démonstration d'incapacité des africains
mais je pense que c'est complètement
hypocrite parce que les africains paix
des taux d'intérêt qui sont très élevées
7 à 8%
l'argent concessionnaires qui est
disponible c'est à dire ceux avec des
taux d'intérêt très bas étant en valeur
beaucoup plus moins importants que ceux
qui étaient disponibles auparavant donc
les économies ont une croissance de
presque 2 fois depuis l'année 2000 et il
n'y a pas deux fois de croissance des
taux concessionnels
donc ce n'est pas une question de
mauvaise gestion c'est la question que
les africains payer des taux d'intérêt
le plus élevé du monde
et donc c'est ça qui est vraiment à
changer je pense que le président qu en
raison professeur le pen on va marquer à
une courte pause à tout de suite sur rt
fou
[Musique]
voilà retour sur rt france pour la
grande interview avec le professeur
carlos lopez ancien secrétaire exécutif
de la commission économique pour
l'afrique des nations unies professeur
lopez ont parlé de la dette africaine
d'une volonté d' emmanuel macron
d'annuler cette dette au delà des
déclarations c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression que cette dette c'est un
problème africain avant tout que les
pays européens finalement ils
s'endettent aussi qu'en pensez vous oui
en effet je pense que la dette publique
est devenue un problème mondial
nous avons des montants de dette autour
de 34 mille milliards de dollars
et donc c'est vraiment historiquement
unique et ça va augmenter
considérablement avec les pays de l'
ocde qui sont les pays riches avec un
ratio de dette par rapport à la richesse
nationale de 120% donc plus que leur
richesse nationale qui va passer
probablement à 150 % à comparer cela
avec l'afrique donc nous sommes à 100 4
160%
donc nous sommes des bons gestes et
gestionnaires de la dette
le problème c'est que les pays africains
ont un service de la dette c'est-à-dire
le paiement d'intérêts qui représente
beaucoup par rapport à ce qu'ils gèrent
en termes d'impôts à terme de pression
fiscale comme on dit et c'est ça qu'il
faut changer donc c'est ça la partie du
doutes concernant la capacité de gestion
des africains moi je suis de l'avis que
les africains doivent faire beaucoup
plus d'efforts pour taxer leurs
économies il s'agit pas de taxer les
pauvres il s'agit de faire moins
d'exemptions d'avoir beaucoup de plus
d'efficacité dans l'appareil fiscale
pour qu'on puisse augmenter la pression
fiscale qui est actuellement autour de
15% pour les moyennes mondiales qui sont
de 35 %
donc il ya de la marche et je pense que
cette partie se justifie et donc ça ne
serait pas une mauvaise idée si on
pardonne cette dette comme une autre
une conditionnalité qui est liée à
l'augmentation de la pression fiscale
afrique ce que vous parlez des
conditionnalités
il ya peut-être une peur aussi la part
du g20 des grandes puissances des
institutions internationales c'est en ce
qui concerne la gouvernance économique
la lutte aussi contre la corruption ça
peut être un frein pour permettre
justement aux au continent de lutter
efficacement contre cette crise
sanitaire mondiale
oui je suis d'accord que la lutte contre
la corruption doit être une priorité
mais je pense que ce n'est pas un
phénomène afrique est un phénomène
mondial trafic illicite des capitaux et
le principal qu'ont responsable de la
corruption en afrique et ça exige des
mesures internationales la commission
économique pour l'afrique avait dans la
période où j'étais en charge lancée tout
un processus d identification des fluxs
de capitaux illicites
nous sommes arrivés au chiffre de 60
milliards de dollars des fluxs illicites
donc ça c'est à peu près une fois et
demie l'aide reçue par le continent et
donc c'est un problème qu'on disait
c'est un problème africain avec une
solution globale alors allègement de la
dette en vue s'agissant de l'aide
internationale il ya aussi un appui du
fonds monétaire international fmi
le risque finalement ce que c'est pas de
voir le continent revenir à la case
départ une case où il se soumet à ses
institutions internationales bon
effectivement nous sommes
en train de vivre une situation qui peut
effacer des réformes économiques
importantes qui ont été faites à
l'afrique depuis l'année 2000 juste pour
donner un exemple les projections du fmi
avant le coc vide pour cette année était
de sorte que l'afrique sorte comme la
région la plus performante 16 de temps
des économies les plus performants de
1000 ventes allaient être en afrique et
la moitié de la population africaine
plus de 600 104 millions de personnes
était prévu de vivre cette année dans
des pays avec une croissance de 7% ou
plus donc ça c'est remarquable
et tout ça ça peut être effacé cela dit
les faits me avec les projections
actuelles qui prévoit vraiment un
retournement de ses projections que qui
était très optimiste mais réaliste nous
dit aussi que il faut il faut aider
l'afrique massivement donc du point de
vue du langage ce que dit le fmi est
très différente qui ce que
l'organisation disait pendant
l'ajustement structurel effet on dit
qu'il faut pas oublier le déficit fiscal
on leur a pas de problème d'inflation
parce qu'il y à la demande qui est très
réprimées nous avons là une situation où
pour sauver les économies africaines il
va falloir créer de la liquidité avec
des des infusions
qui pourrait venir par exemple à travers
le pardon de la dette mais je pense
qu'il faut aller au delà de la dette il
va falloir mettre de l'argent c'est la
dette c'est juste ne pas payer dans
l'avenir ce qu'on doit mais il faut de
l'argent pour pouvoir se tirer
d'affaires pendant cette année et pour
cela il va falloir une solution plus
courageuses qui est d'utiliser ce qu'on
appelle les droits de tirage spéciaux du
fmi qui permettent de l'est budgétaire
directe au pays et qui est utilisé
seulement en temps de crise et ce que je
crois savoir c'est que pendant la
réunion du g20
cette possibilité a été étalée et même
éventuellement soutenu par le fmi mais
n'a pas été suivi par des pays
importants qui ont un droit de veto sur
ses décisions il dit
il faut de l'argent vous dit même qu'il
faut 200 milliards d'euros pour
permettre au continent de combattre la
pandémie de kobe de 19 aces que le
continent a les moyens de mobiliser une
telle femme
non il ya un peu de reprogrammation qui
est possible il ya des pays comme
l'afrique du sud qui peuvent se
permettre d'aider des stimulus un peu
plus consistant et fort mais la plupart
des pays n'ont pas les moyens de le
faire et je pense qu'on a besoin
vraiment de ses droits de tirage
spéciaux comme le mécanisme qui va
permettre d'arriver à des sommes
consistante et moi je suis de l'avis
qu'il faut 2,5 milliards de dollars
même si les ministres africains des
finances dont tout d'abord on demandait
5 milliards dont une partie était
justement consacré à la dette et et
finalement ils ont révisé leurs propres
projections et maintenant il parle aussi
de 200 milliards de 100 milliards de
dollars
il ya des fonds quand même des
initiatives en afrique je pense au fond
que 8,19 initiée par l'union africaine
il s'agit de créer
un de mobiliser le public et le privé au
qu'en pensez vous je pense que ce qui a
annoncé la banque mondiale ce qui a
lancé la bad la banque africaine de
développement la banque export-import
d'afrique afrique simbad d'autres
acteurs comme la badea comme c'est clubs
d'afrique championne qui a justement
lancé cette initiative avec l'union
africaine tout ça c'est vraiment
remarquablement bien venu mais c'est
largement suffisant
insuffisant il ya des projets vous
parlais tout à l'heure des réformes
économiques à des projets on peut citer
la zec un cette zone économique de libre
échange continental aussi l'instauration
d'une monnaie unique en afrique de
l'ouest les qu est ce que tout ça c'est
fait remis en cause par à cause par
cette pandémie remis en cause du point
de vue du calendrier
moi je trouvais par exemple ce qui
concerne la zleca qu'il fallait vraiment
prévoir trois années beaucoup de
discussions des techniques et citron
pour arriver jusqu'aux aux gardes
frontières qui vont effectivement mettre
en place des mesures pour permettre la
circulation des biens et services
je pense que il y avait beaucoup
d'optimisme sur l'aspect technique parce
que il s'agit aussi d'un processus
politique moi je suis très content du
progrès qui a été fait jusqu'à
maintenant mais on avait un sommet qui
était prévu pour le mois de mai qui
n'aura plus lieu on avait prévu que
l'entrée en force au mois de juillet
donc je pense que c'est vrai question
donc on aura des retards mais pas une
remise en cause avec l'écho moi j'étais
de ceux qui défendent est depuis le
début que les cobras la convergence
macroéconomique nécessaire au sein de la
cd rom et n'était pas en place donc
qu'on n'allait jamais voir les coûts en
maintenant je ne peux que dire bon
peut-être que j'avais raison
d'autres plus pessimistes diront que
c'est l'écho ville qui m'a donné raison
merci beaucoup professeur lopez rappelle
que vous êtes l'ex secrétaire
général adjoint de ban ki moon au sein
de l'onu professeur d'économie merci
pour cette grande interview
merci une grande interview que vous
pouvez retrouver en podcast sur notre
site internet
rt france point tv merci de votre
attention et à très bientôt
[Musique]